here's a very odd response that Joe
Biden gave when he was asked whether
releasing the these reserves was a good
idea
what response to Republic
and our release because to help
Democrats in the midterms where have
they been the last four months
that's my response
I think he genuinely means that where
have they been because he doesn't know
where he is so I'll Grant him that uh
virtually every Republican has been
screaming from the top of their lungs
about releasing American Energy and
going for our own stuff right that's
what every Republican has been talking
about let's be energy independent while
the Democrats have been the one saying
no we must have to end fossil fuels it's
just ridiculous so the fact that now
Biden sees the numbers or whoever's in
charge they see the numbers they see the
bloodbath on the way so what are they
doing two weeks before the election
we're diving into the reserves so we can
artificially depress the cost so a few
people will be like that Joe Biden is
doing good gas went from six dollars a
gallon to 450.
here's video of Karin Jean-Pierre being
asked about these uh reserves and uh
yeah she's not very good at her job the
president just said just said no
releases from the Strategic Wars are
were not political but we've seen on a
daily basis that the administration is
making these announcements on abortion
gas prices EV student debt and array of
other programs such as infrastructure
what's the goal of these announcements
given that they're happening so close to
midterms look and the president was
asked specifically that that question on
on the gas prices in our announcement
today and he was very clear he said if
you've watched in these last several
months these last four months I believe
that what is what he said he's been
working every day to lower gas prices
for the American people especially after
we saw Putin's brutal war in Ukraine
which led to Putin's price price hike as
we have seen in the last several several
months guys it's Putin's price hike it's
OPEC it's Saudi Arabia so we have to
empty our reserves and Joe Biden's been
working every day you have no idea how
hard this guy is working uh some of you
may remember the president before Joe
Biden his name was Donald Trump the
media didn't like him very much but we
had a booming economy and our Energy
prices were down and he was actually
refilling our strategic petroleum
reserves even though they were already
full because he wanted to make sure we'd
have way more than we need do you
remember this based on the price of oil
I've also instructed the Secretary of
Energy to purchase at a very good price
large quantities of crude oil for
storage in the U.S strategic Reserve
we're going to fill it right up to the
top
saving the American taxpayer billions
and billions of dollars helping our oil
industry and making us even further
toward that wonderful goal which we've
achieved which nobody thought was
possible of energy Independence
it puts us in a position that's very
strong and we're buying it at the right
price sorrow land right getting energy
at the right price energy Independence
not trying to destroy fossil fuels
etc etc so we had competency now we have
this thing